welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania has
introduced a concept that has confused a
lot of people out there mainly this idea
of there being more than one sacred
timeline in the MCU Multiverse as we see
Kang looking at a model of not one but
two sacred timeline Halos during the
course of the film but why are there two
secret timelines when Loki season 1 only
dealt with traveling across one of them
that's a good question because this is
mighty suspicious let's get into this
mystery to gather my nerd babies because
I like to speculate with my speculation
Nation nerd babies for those of you out
there that don't like me calling you
nerd babies stuck it up because you're
my nerd baby whether you like it or not
just suck it up just get used to it put
the pacifier in your mouth and just shut
the
I'm trying to swear less to appeal to
the Christians but like always be sure
to head on over to nerdriot.shop where
you can pick up one of these amazing
quantumania hoodies or one of our new
Mando inspired merch just got my beanie
in the mail I got a cool Star Wars
beanie it's like written in orabesh but
all right so if you have an eye for
detail then you already know that
quantumania kind of reshaped the general
audience's understanding of the MCU with
just one scene and I'm mainly talking
about the scene when Kang is having his
very hostile reunion with his former BFF
with Benefits Janet Van Dyke and let's
be real there was definitely some
benefits there and this is where he
presents her with a freshly prepared
hologram presentation that consists of
imagery of not one but two sacred
timelines in the MCU Multiverse but what
is up with that exactly so far we've
only seen one sacred timeline being
pruned by the TVA in Loki so why does
King whip out two sacred timelines when
he's warning Janet of the multiversal
incursions and Secret Wars to come well
the quick explanation to this is that
we're looking at two different different
multiversal timelines organized by two
different entities the first one that
Kang lays down while he's talking to
Janet about his foolish variants in the
Council of Kings is the sacred timeline
run by the Council of Kings a sacred
timeline that I believe it will be
called the Kang Dynasty but more on that
in a bit and the second one that Kang
throws up from his hand is the same MCU
secret timeline that Sylvie is now in
charge of that's right y'all I believe
we are in a multi-multiverse now as
weird as that sounds because if you've
been following my theory videos on a
channel over the past like year you'll
probably know that I have been alluding
to this fact that multiple sacred
timelines exist in the MCU meaning that
I believe that there are multiple
bundles of multiverses in the MCU mainly
because the MCU has been pointing to
this in a number of ways like for
example in my video explaining the
hidden sacred timeline that they put in
Multiverse of Madness I pointed out that
multiple variants of the great Cosmic
being the Living Tribunal can be seen
while Doctor Strange in America Chavez
are flying in that weird sequence
implying that each Living Tribunal
watches over one sacred timeline each
for one Multiverse in another example is
my video on how the collector from the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies fled his
native Multiverse at the beginning of
the Loki finale we can see his spaceship
flying away from one of those black
holes before it explodes each of those
black holes represent their own
Multiverse with their own sacred
timelines and look guys I like to live
in the now as in I need energy right now
I don't have time to run to the store to
grab coffee or something so I just pop
one of these a One-Shot energy
um well I feel the energy coming to my
body already Jesus Christ
once your Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everyone really each energy shoe has
75 milligrams of pure caffeine plus 600
milligrams of additional New Tropics to
give you a serious energy boost that
works immediately as you chew and man
does it work like as I was chewing that
I felt the alertness and power coursing
through my veins like put it directly
into my veins I say the focus shoes are
great when you need to concentrate and
they give you a natural boost of energy
with BCD and E vitamins plus zinc to
help with immune system support and the
amino acid tyrosine but my favorite
ingredient is the blue raspberry flavor
rasposine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus that you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals and [__]
so get started with one shot energy
today by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order that
is oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for
10 off your order we think one shot
energy for sponsoring this video and
giving all the viewers the extra shot of
energy energy that they need to survive
and thrive and be nerdy all the time but
why why are there weird glowing Halos of
energy swirling around inside of these
black holes at the end of time well as
I've noted before in previous videos I
believe this black hole imagery in the
Loki finale is meant to show us what the
universe will eventually look like
towards the end of time during an era in
the cosmos known as the black hole era
the point in the distant future when the
cosmos is just black holes and all the
matter and everything that ever existed
on a multi-multi-versal scale gets
sucked into one of these black holes
then whoever is left at this black hole
period at the End of Time whether it be
Sylvie or a version of Kang like he who
remains or multiple Kings like the
Council of Kings or the great Weaver
weaving the web of life and Destiny in
the spider-verse whoever that person is
can sit inside the very center of their
own black hole in their own Multiverse
and manage the flow of the energies of
everything that ever existed in in that
Multiverse as that energy swirls around
them but only for the Multiverse of
timelines inside their own black hole as
we see with he who remains and the MCU
with sacred timeline this is why in the
Loki finale when Kang is telling I'll
never be happy Loki and I want to stab
stabby Loki about when he met his
variants he uses the imagery of multiple
black holes and he is referring to his
perspective of the multiversal conflict
take a look before the TVA a variant of
myself lived on Earth in the 31st
Century he discovered that there were
universes stacked
on top of the Zone this imagery was not
unintentional and this entire moment
ually points to the existence of way
more than two multiversal black holes in
the MCU like that little Kang figure on
hiku remains his desk showed three black
holes but he remains himself said that
they were an infinite a number of kings
that discovered the Kings from other
neighboring multiversal black holes as
well with their own sacred timelines so
basically I think that this means that
when all these Kings met the first time
they were already the he who remains is
of their respective sacred timeline
slash black holes like they were the
winners they beat all of their Kang
variants from their respective
Multiverse and they were like yeah I'm
on top but if this is true the question
Still Remains why are all of these kangs
from different black holes and
multiverses huddled together at the
Council of Kings working on one sacred
timeline that immortus doesn't want to
disturb and why did quantumania Kang
only show us two timelines well I think
that answer was given to us by he who
remains when he tells us how he ended
the multiversal war by weaponizing that
Hungry Hungry Hippo what purple ass
matter eating Cloud eliaith basically a
feeling that there used to be a lot more
multiversal black holes that used to
neighbor these two black holes that we
see in the Loki finale until that piece
between the multi-multiversal Kings
erupted after quantumania Kang started
the multiversal war between Kings then
during that multiversal War I highly
suspect that he who remains weaponized
Elias and wiped out countless sacred
timeline black holes in that process
until that war was over like basically
all those kings that you see in the
Council of Kings at the end of the movie
they're all black holes were probably
destroyed by eliaf until only two black
holes remained nearby and nearby is very
important because they're on an infinite
amount of black holes so I don't think
he can destroy all of them then after
that multiversal war it seems like the
kings that waved the white flag at he
who remains and wanted peace again
became the new Council of Kings under
immortus and made a deal with he who
remains and basically I think that deal
was that the Council of Kings won't
fight anymore so long as he who remains
isolates his native tie timeline and
uses eliev to not let the vines of his
multiversal sacred timeline cross over
into the Council of Kang's backyard
where they have their own timeline
because now all these King survivors
have to share one black hole with one
sacred timeline because all of their
native sacred timelines or multiverses
were destroyed by he who remains so
they're basically all homeless however
the problem is he who remains got really
bored and didn't want to manage the MCU
sacred timeline anymore and so he got
Sylvie to kill him this is really bad
because now Sylvie's MCU sacred timeline
is starting to grow into the other
secret timeline black hole that the
Council of Kings worked so hard to build
together after the war which is why
Immortal says they're beginning to touch
the Multiverse I believe that immortus
is referring to the MCU sacred timeline
beginning to touch the Council of Kings
organized sacred timeline there Kang
Dynasty and I think that this bundle of
timelines could very well hold the fox
X-Men Multiverse and could very likely
as well be the same place for Sylvie
sent Loki at the very end of the Loki
finale to the Council of Kings TVA but
yeah those are what I believe to be the
two main timelines that we see in
quantumania but I do not believe that
they were the only ones we're going to
see in the Multiverse Saga thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at Mass retainment on
Twitter if you guys want to see me tweet
some weird [__] most importantly you can
follow new Roxas wherever we are on the
social media and head on over to
nerdwide.shop again thank you guys so
much for watching I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]